in the Appalachian Mountains near Front
Royal Virginia a tower rises above the
trees
it sits on land owned by the Smithsonian
Institution the tower is part of an
ambitious ecological science project
funded by the National Science
Foundation
it's called Neon Neon is the National
ecological Observatory Network it's
comprised of an array of 20 different
domains each domain has a horse site
like we're at right now in all NSF is
spending about half a billion dollars to
build about 80 neon sites across the
United States some will have towers like
this one that will stay in place for 10
to 30 years the towers are packed with
instruments that measure all kinds of
things temperature sunlight and the
movement of gases between the land and
the air neons goal is to monitor what's
happening to climate land-use and
biodiversity on a continental scale
there's a lot of great science already
out there a lot of long-term ecological
research sites the difference with neon
is that we're compiling a data set where
we're collecting data the same way at
the same time across the continent
around the towers researchers will be
tracking plants and animals including
beetles neon also includes sites at
streams and lakes many researchers are
excited by neons potential
I heard of neon posted five years ago I
was working at Duke I thought to myself
what an audacious project you know to be
part of something like that and the
incites neon produces could have an
influence far beyond science
I think certainly in the future neon
will help inform policy makers neon is
is a tool it's if you will a Hubble the
Hubble Space Telescope pointed back in
the earth we're trying to understand
trends capture those trends describe
them and then also show how those things
are changing our ecosystem once we
understand that I think it'll be much
easier to make decisions that are
grounded in true science